hi guys man it's 6:00 in the morning
yeah there's a trap does they not care
that some people are probably sleeping
here at this hour Jesus Christ trying to
watch an Avenger damn it
hi guys I'm Greg Alba I'm John Humphrey
I'm Andrew I hope you guys caught our
trailer reaction for Avengers endgame
before we hop into our trailer review
breakdown video I just wanted to say
thank you to all hope and following us
on the Stardust app over there it's free
to download free to use we do 30 second
reaction reviews for films TV shows or
trailers lot of them are micro sketches
so be awesome if you could download and
follow us today people really quick I
want to make this clear well we got the
notifications John and I have the same
ones on our phone we got three
notifications about the trailer and each
one of them had their word end games in
a game I even think Marvel Studios
originally had it in there yeah and they
must have changed it right away that's
how we knew it because I said in-game
before I hit the trailer to play it
three people were like oh I think this
might be fake because he said endgame
beforehand uh yeah with how quick we got
that up huh no we couldn't spare extra
two and a half minutes to watch the
whole trailer first there's even a bunch
of interns over at Marvel like poring
over the computer going sweetie should
we take the sub yeah
like is this a big mystery for people
well there was there was other two other
champ trailer channels too that had
endgame in it so I was like that's how
we know it's endgame beerus yeah
people not like twitter was blowing up
with the tyler right yeah like literally
we're all looking for the notifications
at 5 a.m. we're not gonna take the time
to go let's watch the trailer first yeah
then we'll fake our way through it you
know people I think can confuse our
excitement and enthusiasm if we're like
laughing and because it's a very somber
trailer but you know I'm gonna dude
strong impression that even though
there's gonna be some somberness here
this is also gonna be a triumphant movie
despite the fact that there's this like
somber tone throughout prison I get so
giddy with it is because I'm like this
is gonna be like the epic kind of like
how Return of the King was yeah
you have like a bushel of context to go
with it so even though the tone of the
trailer itself is very somber like we
know there like every shot is gonna
bring up a million ideas in your mind
about what would be coming and that's it
was like Hawkeye returned Ronin be there
yeah you're like that's exciting what's
going on with Ronin there Andrew looked
like he was battling the geek the Yakuza
but I mean if just taking the pretty
obvious guess is we're gonna have to
guess that in the decimation that his
family was most likely wiped out now
that's what's driving him and calling
him a you know to become like a lone
warrior now basically what Ronin is you
know it's a Japanese you know name that
refers to you know the masterless
samurai the lone warrior so you know and
also Robert De Niro or Keanu Reeves with
47 one other thing I thought was funny
about this trailer is that both of the
characters that were like very
apparently missing from the first core
yeah I haven't Scott Lang to which
everybody's going nuts about thinking
like maybe is he a scroll or something
like the eggs last time he saw Scott
Lang he's stuck in the quantum realm and
all that but obviously he's using a time
vortex because they said there's just no
message because they're talking about
time yeah yeah with the time travel
device yeah exactly figure that's
probably not what's gonna happen but I
imagine if you didn't see the set photos
that in some ways can feel like a
spoiler yeah decease colouring
especially with knowing how ant-man the
wasp was a mid credit sting went down
man being lost in the quantum realm
showing he's out of the quantum realm
here right I mean if he is this girl
that's on a spoiler it's could be a
mislead I mean the the infinity war
trailer the the first couple were pretty
notorious for being quite misleading
having very iconic shots and they're not
going to yeah exactly all those elements
but I think yeah to me it wasn't really
a small cuz I was like I knew who was
gonna be in it I saw those set photos
which were a spoiler in and of itself we
knew from the end of ant-man the wasp
and I think would be reinforced but the
fact that he's like pulled out and going
to them I could see how some I viewed as
a spoiler but for me I'm just giddy that
he is you I think it's kind of stupid it
criticized us for getting excited for so
much of this so I'm like despite it's
somber tones there's there's still
plenty of cool no
some like rode in and ant-man in here
just seeing them all - it's starting off
somber because it's probably gonna be a
lot of triumphs here well what I I mean
me as a viewers sometimes I'll laugh at
things that I find clever particularly
interesting and I don't know how
everyone's gonna respond to this trailer
but I kind of liked the approach that
they took because I remember the
original Infinity Ward trailer being
pretty jam-packed with a lot of things
and I liked that they went with an
opposite approach to this I love the
stuff with Tony in space just talking to
his helmet recording yes it is and then
yeah we cut back to earth and we get at
least an idea of our few main players in
the overall tone not a lot beyond that I
mean the big surprise is Ronan and then
you know the fun tag with ant-man I feel
like that's all I needed from this
trailer because I want a little mystery
going forward and you said it best - I
mean this trailer like how it just
reassembles at the end it's about you
know reassembling and like it's we've
got the original team from the first
movie back you know to bring about to
fix what happened at the end of
obviously yeah and I like the credit -
with the Marvel Studios or the decimated
us yeah yeah I'm like that's freaking
cool to me that they did that yeah and
the one shot of Thanos was walking
through the field with the Scarecrow
yeah you know like they've been his best
like we saw a Easter Egg video just
yesterday were because I read the
Infinity Gauntlet comic book and I
completely forgot about the end of that
where they have the fan o0 yeah on the
farm area in an infinity war you can see
like a snippet of it in the very corner
it's like so you have to really pay
attention and zoom in on it a little bit
straighter than am just a very big
close-up moved is she like Oh an empty
farm I know I made some crack about
shouldn't nebula be there in the trailer
reaction but pretty sure nebula is on
that ship you know they have a moment in
here where nebula is on the ship it's
probably it's a big ship this time and
also to her and Tony were the only ones
who survived Titan untighten that would
make the most sense absolutely and you
pointed out that in the photos and that
when they were saying that then I'll so
I've got half of all living creatures
which is cool clarification because I
remember Kevin Feige came out and said
yeah half
everything how all living things they've
got wiped out they cut out parts of the
montage row it was like a deer fading
yeah yeah yeah that's breathe a
cockroach yeah I'm glad they didn't have
been heartbreaking so they clarify that
but in that moment where they have
Scarlett Johansson's Black Widow voice
overlapping it you point out they have a
photo Cherie they're on screwdrive join
this sure he was wiped out yeah we saw
Scott Lang's photo on there and then we
saw Cherie which is why they got
confused when they saw Scott Lang in the
video like I said no message because he
was on that yeah on that board they must
have thought that because he's lost in
the corner right exactly been God does
exactly maybe they found like Hank Pym
and Janet Pimm's like stuff whatever
happens at the end of ant-man and the
wasp they found the van but no Scott
yeah I'm kind of wondering if the Sheree
element of that photo cuz because the
Russos know that they that people
dissect these trailers to a teat do we
know yeah I'm doing it right now
people really hyper analyze these
trailers so I imagine they might have
just thrown that image of their a of
Sheree just to mislead us oh no because
they didn't didn't show her vanish in
the first one and I feel like she might
be a major contributing player perhaps
to maybe getting ant-man out of the
quantum realm or something like that
because she's gonna be a big factor in
it I don't fully believe it exactly I
won't those tiny yeah yeah I don't I
don't fully believe maybe she's just
missing yeah yeah say maybe it's just
everybody that we don't have a handle on
right now or have eyes on you could be
right but I'll just say that mbaku is
running what kinda now so if she was
around which he maybe be running it
because it's in her family
I don't know yeah it's true when I swing
this is a fascinating thing about
advertising to me now is you watch a
trailer like this and like not every
trailer but especially like an Avengers
great trailer you know that there's
nothing in here that wasn't thought
about and tweaked meticulously Oh
totally and yeah now at the rate at
which they're willing to show us things
that are intentionally misleading and
like you pointed out earlier the way
they'll just flat-out lie about like no
and game's not the title at this point I
see a trailer and I'm just like I'm not
a hundred percent sure
to expect based on this cuz like yeah I
gotta imagine that everything is meant
to be there to either mislead or to
delete me and I'm not even sure why
people are upset about the endgame title
some people don't really like that and
I'm like why what's wrong with that dr.
strange likes it we're in the endgame
yeah I like it mostly because of that
yeah it's like it seems like a fitting
sound we won't know until we see the
movie obviously but you know having to
come out of that line and him alluding
to the one version where we win this if
it's you guys were also talking about
Tony talking to his helmet like that I
mean we were talking about like how he
felt trapped and isolated that kind of
felt like the first movie where he's
trapped and isolated in a cave he's got
to think his way out of the problem and
you know do the same thing I also kind
of got a reference back to Iron Man 3
where he's talking to the mask and
leaving a message for pepper because an
Iron Man 3 that's what happened when I
think he went to Tennessee when the yeah
yeah I took him there and then he leaves
a you know a message for pepper letting
him know he's still alive
yeah and he's trying to get back to her
as best he can so it kind of was a
little reference and obviously that's
his motivation on top of I mean I would
assume you know getting the half the
universe back on top of what happened
with Peter Parker but his motivation
obviously is kind of odd
I mean I'm very excited for this movie I
feel like there's plenty of reasons to
get giddy when you're watching this
trailer because the trailer with the
Marvel Studios logo is the decimating
effect and then this isn't happening the
snapping happening with the snapping in
and then at the end it's like the logos
coming back together so I feel like this
is a triumph of the last one ends on
such a downer tone and then this one
will probably start off on a downer but
then and maybe with some somberness may
be Captain America dies I don't know
maybe a few people die but they're
obviously gonna bring back at least most
of the people who were go ahead snapped
away so I imagine that it's gonna be a
child for feeling yeah well that's what
what sits nicely about the title for me
as it seemed it does feel like the end
of a chapter of something yeah it feels
like the end of a piece and then we'll
transition into something well I mean
this movie is the culmination so far of
everything that's happened I mean it's
just all right I mean even though
obviously we know there's gonna be
way more MCU films after this but at
least for the original team it's kind of
like you know spinning that bow at the
end worst rapper rapping that both if
you will you know just again just a
culmination of everything but I will say
one thing I did really appreciate in
this trailer I love seeing Captain
America gets so emotional then we saw
him you know with that picture yeah yeah
that was really cool all this time he's
on the road with Black Widow and he's
still thinking about come on man she's
survived that was my favorite part of
Civil War I didn't find it weird at all
I prefer the beard look oh you think CGI
but yet to me I think it's gonna be
great you know we like to nitpick these
things I see a lot of people kind of
crap on the Captain Marvel trailer as
well and I'm like come on guy I think a
lot of time when you look back at some
MCU films that were generally perceived
as bad or disappointing
they had great trailers and a lot of the
movies that my head shows over a little
lackluster they end up delivering pretty
good movies and I think Captain Marvel
is gonna be pretty good and endgame like
I like the title
I like everything we got here I like
that it's subtle approach I really love
it so you know yeah the point of a
trailer isn't to stand in for me yes
just to pitch you the elements as best
that it can you know you can call me a
Marvel fan boy even though I'm one of
the few people who gladly admits how
much I really love Justice League it's
not about being a marvel fan enough Greg
you have so much trust in this that I I
highly doubt that it's gonna be bad at
all and yeah there's been so much hype
for this trailer people are probably
going to find this a little lackluster
but I'm like who's gonna be out in a few
months guys don't worry it's a few
months from now April come on we got a
few months all right guys well what do
you think of the Avengers end game
trailer you guys can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
bell and check out Andrew Gordon on the
movie source channel and download it
falls on the star to us at read it
download free to use dude today